yeah I like big butts I like big butts
on men and women I want a big butt but
because I'm a guy I don't feel like I'm
allowed to want a big butt everybody
wants a nice ass well I think anyone
with a bigger butt gets a lot of
attention his butt booster right away it
kind of feels like a bra so there's like
the title tag and then on the back but
there's no other information here's my
flab mat oh my god I'm so happy and so I
just put the underwear on my pants feel
very filled out and these pants I like
usually totally filled out by just my
natural ass but like damn I sat down in
a chair right after I put this on and I
can tell why people with big butts have
such big egos because they're so high up
and I'm into it it'll be interesting to
see if anybody else can tell the
difference you're pissing tight Oh God
why isn't so hard it kind of feels like
a real butt oh that's a firm butt thank
you so much yeah I did um I did people
do squats for a month
ya know I'm a weird
one benefit of the big butt that I will
miss is that when I sit on people's laps
they don't talk about how bony my cheeks
are I think before I thought I was more
unhappy with the shape of my butt than I
actually a.m. and I think going through
this she made me realize I actually
don't want the explosive like Nicki
Minaj but that I think I want I think I
had the most fun I've had in a really
long time the grass is greener let me
tell you it's fuller - what do you think
I think I like the real thing better
h-huh